the jurogan experience
and this is where we find ourselves with
elon musk about to buy twitter yeah i
saw that apparently it's going down it
happened oh [ __ ]
what oh [ __ ]
the press release has been announced
elon musk just bought twitter we got a
movie star
type of a superhero it's like a movie
like if you had a movie and there was a
guy who was like a like a hero in the
movie who happened to be a billionaire
does wild [ __ ]
like makes his own rockets and drills
under the city and
electric cars
insane elon musk agrees to buy twitter
in a 44 billion deal agreement to take
social media network private marks the
close of dramatic courtship here's why
that's going to be interesting yeah tell
me i need to hear what you think he
believes that free speech
is
important and not just important vital
for a democracy for a functioning
democracy and i agree with that
and what's interesting about this is
we're gonna
look we found out some things about
twitter and one of the things they do is
shadow ban people so they make it so
that your your content whatever you put
out has less impact it has it has less
engagement they limit your ability to
express yourself
they've they ban accounts and they ban
accounts if that account says something
that they don't agree with if the
account says something that violates
what they believe
also this ability to uh shadow ban
people has to be exposed right that
happens on tick tock i i was just never
that clip you just saw yes where i call
i said i should be sure it was about me
and my body and how i felt yeah it was
taken down and i was put on probation
well tick tock is
is
it's the roughest yeah well i think they
don't want anything that interrupts ad
revenue and anything that gets yeah can
someone buy tick tock and please maybe
you'll want to buy tick tock next jesus
maybe the chinese won't sell maybe if
they sell it it'll be like one of them
deals like they you think you bought it
but there's nothing in it i doubt
someone's gonna sell they're real
they're not gonna sell tick tock that
they're they're really the worst they're
the tick tock's the worst
i can't believe i didn't think they were
gonna um
that was gonna happen with him on on
twitter that's amazing apparently it was
really close yesterday and i had heard
um this morning that it was probably
going to happen but the fact that it's
now announced that's [ __ ] amazing
look it'll change everything and i
wonder how quickly uh it is before
donald trump's back he said he's not
coming i think he'd i already saw a
thing he said he's not going to come
back even if elon bought it i didn't see
a reason why but that's all right i'll
tell you exactly why because of his
truth social
um social media why are we playing
around with this twitter [ __ ] will be on
truth social is that big that's donald
trump's
is it big the biggest
is it it's the best
it's the biggest
the biggest of all time
they say that twitter's not as big
donald trump says i'm not going back to
twitter even with elon musk taking over
donald reconsider